هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره بدا
صباح اليوم سريان اتفاق لوقف القتال في
جميع انحاء البلاد لمده 24 ساعه وذلك
برعايه سعوديه امريكيه وقد افدى مراسل
الجزيره بسماع ذوي اطلاق نار متقطع في
العاصمه السودانيه بعد بدء سريان الهدنه
كما شوهدت اعمده الدخان تتصاعد في سماء
العاصمه واضاف ان طائرات الحربيه قصفت قبل
دقيقتين من بدء الهدنه الجديده موقعا جنوب
الخرطوم بحري بينما ردت المضادات الارضيه
على القصف
قال مصدرنا حكومي سوداني للجزيره ان
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان بقياده عبد
العزيز الحلو حركت قوات من منطقه البراما
في ولايه جنوب كردفان على نحو اربعين كيلو
مترا من عاصمه الولايه وهاجمت الجيش في
اربع مناطق واستولت على معدات عسكريه
واسرت افرادا من الجيش السوداني
في ولايه غرب دار فور افاد مراسلنا بتصاعد
اعمده الدخان في مدينه الجنينه وابي سماع
سكان مدينه ادريس
متقطعا للمدافع الثقيله نتيجه الاشتباكات
التي صاحبها انقطاع النقل للاتصالات
وجهت وزاره العد الامريكيه 37 تهمه
فيدراليه للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب ابرزها التامر على العداله واحيازه
وثائق سريه والادلاء بشهادات كاذبه واكد
الادعاء تعرض امن البلاد للخطر وقال
المدعي الخاص المكلف بالتحقيقات ان فريق
التحقيق يسعى لتسريع في اجراءات محاكمه
ترامب وان القانون الامريكي يطبق على
الجميع
هذا هو النفع ودفع عن احتفاضه بالوثائق
كما انتقد رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
مكارثي توجيه قائمه اتهام ضد اضاف ان
الولايات المتحده تعيش يوما مظلما وان
بايضا يوجد في نفس موقف تشامبي
قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديميرا بوتين في
كلمه له من سوتشي ان القوات الاوكرانيه
بدات في شن هجومها المضاد منذ خمسه ايام
مشيرا الى تكبدها خسائر كبيره في صفوفها
حسب قوله
قالبي يا منسق لاتصالات بمجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان روسيا قد استخدمت
مسيرات ايرانيه لمهاجمه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
اكد رئيس هيئه اركان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه في محادثات عبر تقنيه الفيديو مع
نظيره الصيني على ضروره ان تظل التدريبات
العمليه والقتاليه المشتركه نهجا مهما في
اطار التعاون العسكري بين موسكو
نقل موقع عكسيوس الاخباري عن مصادر مطالعه
ان مسؤولين امريكيين وايرانيين اجرى
محادثات غير مباشره في عمان الشهر الماضي
كما نقل الموقع عن مصادر ان تبادل الرسائل
بين الوفدين هدفه الوصول الى تفاهم بشان
برنامج ايران النووي
من جهاتها اعلنت ممثليه تيران في الامم
المتحده انه لا يوجد اتفاق مؤقت بديل
للاتفاق النووي على جدول الاعمال
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]